[Music]
there's a multi-millionaire who claims
to have invented a dry and safe place
for homeless people to sleep in and can
you guess what he used to invent it
life-sized Tupperware hardware box ah
shamwows very absorbent tarp
did you see you could have looked like a
life-sized Tupperware yeah why what's
the funniest else leave hey thank you
yeah so I'm gonna play a video clipping
you will be demonstrating to you his
invention two trash cans you think like
The Millionaire baby how you gonna break
this to trash bin what's up that's
that's steel pipe this guy's a man the
bigger question is if you're homeless
where do you get some money to buy the
[ __ ] trash hundred ten dollars this
guy who is making 64 bucks a day
oh okay so it only take him a week to
find out man is taking two days hundred
pounds oh so he can use the the two
trash cans as a cart - yeah you know but
we're gonna have so many of those on the
street though it's gonna be like a
scooter program all right and then is
like they're long they're like those two
would be these tables together actually
even a little longer so we're just gonna
have a bunch of red trash cans on the
street why would they buy it if they
could just Jack us wait wait Jack our
trash can yeah that's another thing
nobody wants to fashion that put it
together zo and it smells
already dirty dough that's right yeah so
people on social media that were saying
that this is demeaning why homeless
people in trash bins like so they'd
rather leave them in the rain they're
fine with them eating out of a trash can
how would you dare put somebody in a
clean trash can food in the trash can
hey you stop dehumanizing these people
just walk around them like argh you
don't make eye contact don't make a step
over oh my god come on I would call this
the ox Oscar mm the Oscar because Oscar
the Grouch lives in a trash can
Larry I get why mm mm yeah that's right
Oscar mm but he's still alive is he
still mm yeah he's still alive he's
still alive but isn't it still mm though
like he's in the mm right that's why
it's mm oh isn't it like a like a future
version a rare sight I thought he was
trying to say it's from the future no
he's trying his right now from the
future yeah because it's yeah cause it's
more like tech because it's two trash
cans so I thought he was are you living
in a nine did you try a scares are high
tech I will say that's a lot of shoulder
pad Gio has enough shoulder pad maybe
she's living in the night you could come
soup now Wow he do shoulder reductions
they do
sounds like a wooden hanger it looks
like she shoved a hanger okgo how about
this just don't wear solder pads okay
you got to cover your shoulder pads you
wanna block you ladies blazer damn you
went from making her feel dumb for what
she said to make her feel ashame I don't
know nor do I feel ashamed Jim don't
wear shoulder pads because already as it
is when you go to a nice restaurant
they're like I would ask to hang up your
company you've already a
multi-millionaire because he his company
was one of the convicted trash cans no
she was UK's first commercial Internet
provider but anyway that's how he made
his money you should stick to Internet
because there's that invention suck ass
well he was saying that he came up with
this idea when he was inventing a single
thing we sought to homeless people
fighting for a trashcan daeul's wait if
I just come by the - how dare you give
the back story of how he came up with
this idea he was trying to create an
electric car out of bins so out of trash
everything he does is out of trash cans
like what the [ __ ] he's not like I was
hoping my stepdad take off the trash and
I bumped into a [ __ ] trash can I fell
into another trash can I was like oh
that would have been a great backstory
see the funny thing is like he could
have used it tantor he could have used
something I don't know like this is no
cuz tip what sucks about this is he was
trying to make an electric car yeah and
then he came up with the double trashcan
thing with the hinge he said that he
came up with this after he had heard
that that homeless people were there
were getting soaked and that they were
getting kicked on the street so that
[ __ ] that don't want them to have
trash cans ya know so then he was saying
like you
have like wet sleeping bags getting
kicked and it seems like oh we could
create this like kind of like shelves
yeah a shell that wouldn't be yeah well
you can roll it though that's the
problem he could call it an invention if
you made like a pod like an egg calling
them sleeping pod that's not a pot those
are [ __ ] two trash cans that someone
else invented you [ __ ] yeah if you push
them together create a pod this is like
this like me and T here got together and
sold some [ __ ] to NASA I believe they
would yeah the module it's a [ __ ]
it's of module yeah cool we'll give you
a billion dollars for this module we'll
take it no wonder they always need
funding see ya true true yeah so how
much should be were light are you
[ __ ] kidding me hating less if he
created like a little window where you
can see their face does that Devil
matter how uh because now it's less
humane because it looks like you're just
shoving them into two trash cans but now
if there's a window though look at geo
geo from on high
give them a window what's more you mean
you can see what's happening where the
kicks come from where the kids come from
where the kicks will be stopped
hopefully with the trashcan trashcan
they could just see the whole thing yeah
but then they could see inside yeah and
not only that yes no privacy and he's
not gonna win y'all just let it be great
man
let them be great he's trying to have to
be now what I will say is that like he's
like it's time to go you just separate
them he put a little stick out he's like
you just put one inside the other and he
no but like if you got all your stuff
like work words your stuff gonna be out
when you go to sleep
when you turn it into the pie I don't
think he actually talked to a homeless
person before you built
and mention that he spent a whole ten
minutes inside one of them so he says
it's very comfortable if you're tall
you're [ __ ] a whole two minutes it's a
long time oh that's generally how long
people sleep throughout the night -
there's ten minutes yeah I still
homeless that's the that's the thing if
I could just sleep wake up sleep wake up
yeah and turn out turn over because of
ambient noises and [ __ ] and discomfort
we had sucks mainly discomfort
yeah sometimes Pete where would you
sleep if you're a homeless me Hotel no
it has to be on the streets
I would I would try to find an overpass
of a highway or like overpass or like
like where it's like that way you
already have kind of built-in shelter
it's it's you're gonna judge us for
answer I'm not gonna answer Joe it is
loud but I mean like you save money then
you buy some hippos if you don't spend
$100 on two trash cans but a thousand a
phone oh then they go to 7-eleven may be
charging a phone outside of 7-eleven all
the time I have fun I'm only letting you
know because me and my friends like to
go smoke weed under the overpass with
homeless people uh-huh so that's what I
realized I was like how do you sleep
here actually been thinking about this
we're gonna have an answer give me your
answer I will find one of those slides
at the playground that are covered on
the top and I would sleep in there
because when you lay in it it's actually
pretty comfortable yeah but and you
slowly slide down throughout the night
no no you just know that the bottom of
it cuz I've actually labeled I laid in
one and you don't way to remove can at
the bottom of it it's done that's a good
idea
okay no no me and Nikki lived next to a
park yeah they had a curfews like six
o'clock p.m. or some [ __ ] yeah you're
out there at six [ __ ] 15 p.m. some
[ __ ] crazy white lady's calling the
cops and they're coming up to you and be
like yo why are you guys at the park
that's why you got do it in a Mexican
neighborhood or Mexican sleep but yeah I
sneak back in like ten o'clock the the
park turns to a gang initiation site so
is it my only what time is that it maybe
I can get there after
gorgey did a trip The Cribs have it
right after the Mexican scripts have it
right okay I get it so it's really a
scheduling thing you have to go to the
parks calendar it's just kind of like
schedule what days you need to go sleep
so where do I go I don't know where to
I'm homeless and I don't want to go I
was thinking about this and I think one
of the best places to sleep is you know
what your trash cans on the floor on a
freeway you know how they have those
like little patches of forest land oh
yeah in the middle like in the middle
planting stuff yeah Wow - it is
paralyzed that's more loud than being
underneath yeah constant white noise
where it doesn't feel like it's loud all
right fine I give up I won't be homeless
or live in a house there's too much
noise there's another place if you could
sneak on top of a rooftop yeah how do
you think all your showed up there for
homeless exactly how you stay up there
Wow you think this through Joe you got
to get a backpack that's it your whole
life is in a backpack yeah that's so
insensitive you think they're getting
you their whole lives in the back that's
sucks choice I'm leaving people yes that
doesn't make it right it doesn't Joe say
sorry you know I thought that is because
I met a homeless guy in Pasadena and he
told me that's what he does
were sleeping together he goes yeah he's
like I just got kicked out I'm like what
do you do then he's like oh I find
buildings and I sleep on top of them I'm
homeless
and I was like that's genius so it's
okay to say because you have a homeless
friend is that it a token homeless man a
guy he's bad guy oh my friend told me
wait it's okay guys my best friend is
homeless why is he your best friend and
we're not give them an Alicia couch oh
come in my shower cuz the [ __ ] smells
the shower and bathroom up so oh yeah
what a good friend
[Music]
[Music]